das ist eine diskussion die gar nicht so
leicht ist nämlich weil viele leute
haben eine komplett falsche vorstellung
davon was genmanipulation bedeutet einer
meiner lieblingsfilme wenn es darum geht
das auch wissenschaft makurath
dargestellt wird ist das generell
denkbar dass er quasi das blut dann da
konserviert wird und an 10.000 jahre
später wieder raus will wird man dann
tatsächlich die dna von den dinosauriern
bekommen kann vielleicht eher anfangen
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
wissenschaftler reagieren heute haben
wir wieder ganz viele filme dabei und
auf meiner rechten seite sitzt christian
altmeier die ihr tatsächlich schon
erkennen könntet aus einem vorherigen
video von mir nämlich haben wir zusammen
über schleimpilze und bist jetzt
promoviert aber immer noch an der uni
bremen im fachbereich bio persönlichen
uns auf meiner linken seite des 203 im
ford den manche von euch vielleicht vom
mit dem korrekt podcast kennen könnten
du bist aber tatsächlich auch normaler
wichtiger physiker eben normal und
physiker ist und was heißt noch mal
genau das fachgebiet experimentalphysik
eigentlich also diamant epitaxie habe
ich mal gemacht also ich hab sind
ethische diamanten gemacht hat dann
gucken wir uns heute filme an doch der
erste finden sollte jeder kennen
ja nur nehmen sie doch dann richtig
und dazu kann ich schon sogar was sagen
glaube ich zu der szene in dem moment
genau wenn ihr danach stoppen könnte das
ist ja der der den jurassic park
eröffnet hat und erfunden haben und er
hat da so einen gehstock wo man auch
schon direkt sieht da oben bernstein
objekt drauf also der knauf ist sondern
standen darin entdeckt eingeschlossen
also um es mal vorwegzunehmen natürlich
geht es ja darum dinosaurier wieder
entstehen zu lassen durch das klonen von
dem blut was in dieser mücke ist was von
den dinosauriern gesamt wurde diese
mücke die da drin ist die ist extra
richtig groß also eine ganz ganz große
art ist das problem ist nur daran dass
es die einzige mücken sorgt die es gibt
die kein blut saugt
man kann anhand der schüler männchen und
weibchen unterscheiden und die hat
irgendwie so franken an den schülern
dann wurde sozusagen gesagt das ist eine
männliche mücke aber männliche mücken
stechen leider sowieso nicht also selbst
bei der ist bei mücken sollten die
stechen machen die menschen halt nicht
so
verpackt dass
gleich der anfang
und trotzdem die frage ist das generell
denkbar dass er quasi das blut in dem
moskito konserviert wird und dann 10.000
jahre später wieder rausgeholt wird man
dann tatsächlich die dna den es von den
dinosauriern bekommen kann also es gibt
forschungen nach der die halbwertszeit
von dna ungefähr 500 20 jahre beträgt
das bedeutet die älteste dna die man
noch finden könnte also egal wie sie
konserviert würde könnte maximal sowie
258.000 jahre alt sein dinosaurier
drehen wir ungefähr von 66 70 millionen
jahre oder so also millionen es gibt
natürlich jetzt auch schon bestrebungen
aus ausgestorbenen tieren irgendwie dna
zu extrahieren und damit die wieder zum
leben zu erwecken
ich denke jetzt gerade einmal mut gehört
so im permafrostboden sensation in
russland mammuts entdeckt mit flüssigen
blut so und da ist natürlich die idee
wie das ensi park angelegt dass man sagt
wir wollen
ausgestorbene arten wieder zum leben
erwecken das ist nicht so ganz weit weg
findet dass die moralische das jetzt
gerade so mammut oder etwas was weißt du
vielleicht sogar der eigene hund enge
gestorben ist da gibt es ein paar
millionäre die würden dann sagen ich
will unbedingt wieder haben ist das
ethisch vertretbar
also wird nicht
geben meint also irgendwie millionär
hass der da eben design viel
wiederbeleben will das halt nicht der
gleiche hund naja das ist halt ein
anderer hund also ich schreibe ich will
das machen würde ethisch vertretbar das
ist eine diskussion die gar nicht so
leicht ist für mich weil viele leute
haben eine komplett falsche vorstellung
davon was genmanipulation bedeutet wenn
man sich zum beispiel mal die diskussion
um saatgut anguckt dahin alle auf die
barrikaden wenn sie irgendwie gehen
meist oder so weiter hören dabei ist das
relativ genau gehen manipulation im
vergleich zu dem was man so in den
fünfziger sechziger jahren gemacht hat
das hieße tomekk gardening - die
pflanzen saatgut lässt die wachsenden
passen die mitte eine fette radioaktive
quelle und gucken was so an mutationen
drumherum passiert und wenn da irgendwas
ist gut aussieht das müsste dann und
züchter für weiter also darf man früher
gemacht und heute wäre man in der lage
das sehr genau zu machen also einzelne
gene an oder aus man muss gucken was
dann passiert da gehen alle leute auf
die barrikaden aber die sachen die man
damals gemacht hat die heute weit
verbreitet sind diese worte hat kein
problem mit werden da kamen unsere
gentechniker ins spiel thinking machines
supercomputer und gibt die eier die
züchten ja die die gegenwart aber die
embryos in diesen eiern was sind denn
das für ein wo haben die nets dino eier
her dachte die sind ausgestorben wie es
also ich also die idee von den mammuts
zweier dass sie zum beispiel elefanten
geboren werden und ich glaube man könnte
hier ähnliches machen also wir machen
falls eine ähnliche spezies hat dann
würde man quasi die in den mutterleib
strauß
stelle mir gerade so ein handelsübliches
huhn vordersten terex
abschließend theoretisch machbar aber
leider nicht mit malaria dms die haben
wir leider verloren die es für immer im
strom der zeit
wurde es nochmal zu optimieren
eigentlich ist es eher nicht stressig
sein kritisches park heißen
die meisten dinosaurier die gezeigt
werden so der terex oder so gekommen er
in der kreidezeit vor und nicht im jura
das ist das
kino entschuldigen sie pinsel hatte und
den in den e hier kann es auch wenn er
rausgeht einfach mit ihrem plakat vorbei
mit zum dicken edding
hey leute ganz kurze unterbrechung ich
weiß ja nicht wie es euch geht aber bei
wissenschaftler reagieren videos bekomme
ich immer mega los die filme direkt
nochmal komplett selber zuschauern
jurassic park gibt es doch bestimmt bei
netflix oder mist ich bin ja ein büro
gar nicht eingeloggt wie war noch mal
ein passwort
[Musik]
welches andere super sichere passwort
gibt es denn noch was ich auf alle meine
accounts verwendet ach ja genau ich habe
es
dir was also ich natürlich auch nicht
und sowieso ich gucke im büro natürlich
niemals filme aber falls sie da so einen
freund oder eine kollegin hat dann
erzählt dir nochmal von nord psp es ist
ein passwort-manager der euch extrem
sichere und vor allem individuelle
passwörter generiert und sie sicher in
der cloud speichert so dass ihr darauf
mit bis zu sechs geräten zugreifen
können so müsst ihr sie euch nicht
selber merken und ihr könnt sogar noch
zeit sparen da nord psp auf ihre
passwörter direkt für euch ein gibt wenn
ihr das wollt also nie wieder bei
freunden ähnlich am laptop überlegen ob
das netflix passwort jetzt das gleiche
ist wie bei amazon prime glaubten ja
dann glaubt mir nicht aber 123456 ist
leider immer noch das populärste
passwort der welt und sehr einfach zu
erraten um zu verhindern dass jemand auf
euren nacken alle jurassic park
hingeguckt könnt ihr jetzt mein passwort
nutzen nämlich den code doktor watson um
70 prozent rabatt auf ein zwei jahres
abo nord peres zu bekommen und dazu
gibt's noch ein gratis monat und tod
geht das verrauchte diesem webseite oder
klickt den ersten link unten in der
video beschreibung um alle eure accounts
sofort sicherer zu machen und falls sie
doch wieder zu waits oder computer
zurück wollt was ich nicht empfehlen
würde könnte innerhalb von 30 tagen
kündigen und bekommt euer geld zu
bis juni geht
das ist perfluorcarbon und nennt sich
das und das ist eine flüssigkeit die
sehr stark mit sauerstoff angereichert
ist das ist nämlich einer meiner
lieblingsfilme wenn es darum geht das
auch wissenschaftler akkurat dargestellt
wird und dass man mal ein positives
beispiel hat und nicht nur sieht was
alles nicht funktionieren kann und in
der flüssigkeit ist einfach ganz viel
sauerstoff gelösten das perfluorcarbon
so diese diese ruhe seine flüssigkeit
hier gerade in diese schüssel da
abgefüllt wurde
und die rate hat auch ein bisschen panik
und fand auch nicht so gut ich glaube
das wurde auch ein paar mal gedreht weil
dazu dann auch mal nicht zu erleichtern
sie bisschen angst habe also das wasser
ist dann irgendwann nicht mehr so rosa
naja jedenfalls das gibt es tatsächlich
wirklich also diese dieser dieses pfc
meist die rate einatmet das wurde schon
mal experimentell auch an menschen
getestet die designer und genau dieses
eingearbeitet haben ist man kann sich
das überlegen für manche leute die die
verletzung der lunge haben also wie zum
beispiel ganz heiße asche oder so
eingeatmet haben also im feuer die wurde
junge nicht mehr gut funktioniert geht
das besser weil man diese flüssigkeit
sehr stark mit sauerstoff auf sättigen
kann die lunge kann wir heilen die
können das eine zeitlang echt ein abend
ohne probleme also wird halt im
krankenhaus benutzt zu therapeutischen
zwecken und es wird auch überlegt ob das
wirklich bald auch system zum einsatz
kommen könnte atmen funktioniert ja gar
nicht dass wir uns zu stellen also
muskeln quasi ein unterdruck in der
lunge erzeugung des einsaugen so eine
flüssigkeit setzte eine ganz andere
geschichte als irgendwie gas durch die
muskulatur das hinkriegen also ist die
flüssig er einzuziehen auch wieder aus
zu mir das führt das funktioniert also
das einzige was was ein bisschen
unangenehm ist und problematisch ist
wenn man damit aufhört also wenn mal
wieder luft atmen soll da muss die lunge
komplett ausgesaugt werden und die muss
auch gespült werden also das ist nicht
so ganz schön man kann es aber
hinkriegen in dem film ist es kein trick
oder so es ist nichts es ist eine echte
ratte und es ist wirklich dieses bfc
diese flüssigkeit diese latte macht
flüssigkeit atmung in dem moment
man sieht wirklich wie die ratte
schlüssigkeit ein arbeit
da geht es richtig gut und findet die
würde das ganz toll
er hat keine angst bekommt man solche
die aufnahmen wollte noch durch so einen
ethikrat mann
der mit so einer universität in den usa
kollaboriert ich weiß gar nicht genau
welche aber die haben tatsächlich
sowieso ein labor gehabt wo die dann
trank vorstellen damit und die haben das
alles zur verfügung gestellt die ganzen
sein und die hatten das aber vorher die
genehmigung
vom ethikrat irgendwie bestätigt dass
das nicht geht ihren unnötiges leid
zufügt oder so
also verschieben wenn man sie ansieht
wird immer nicht denken dass jetzt der
selben art gehören tun sie nicht wir
sehen euch idee und fingerhut und das
soll an einer pflanze wachsen
alles zurück zu einem streit es muss
also dieselbe art sein es ist dieselbe
grenze
es ist als würden sie sich in ständiger
mutation befinden gut oder bösartig
der mutation ist erst mal nicht gut oder
bösartig die ist einfach mutter also das
ist einfach dna die ihr ding macht und
ob das jetzt schlecht oder gut ist osten
werden januar und was habt ihr in den
puff völlig durcheinander gebracht
diesen fast aus wie hannah denken sie es
handelt sich um eine kreuzung
sie merkt kreuz umzusetzen
ja also kommt kann ab und zu mal
vorkommen also wenn die nah genug
verwandt sind es gibt immer mal wieder
hybriden also man kann löwen und tiger
beispielsweise kreuzen man kann zebras
und pferde und esel und das sind auch
tatsächlich verschiedene arten aber das
ergebnis davon kann sich da selber nicht
mehr fortpflanzen faultiere oder so sind
steril jetzt haben wir ein krokodil und
high und dass man erst mal nicht nur
verschiedene arten sondern auch auf dem
stammbaum des lebens an komplett
verschiedene ort angesiedelten hai lebt
irgendwo in der tiefsee und sohn
alligators er so ein sumpf bewohner auch
wenn es salzwasserkrokodile zwar auch
gibt aber erstmal der lebensraum würde
sich überhaupt nicht überschneiden das
eine ist eine relative ist anderen fisch
also sowas von komplett unterschiedliche
organismen die dna wer einfach nicht
kompatibel und selbst mir jetzt einen
wissenschaftler hingehen würde und im
labor eine eizelle vom hai
befruchten mit einem krokodil spermien
oder andersrum dann würde das einfach
nicht funktionieren wahrscheinlich haben
die noch nicht mal die selbe anzahl von
chromosomen
haben schon irgendwie ist dieses gebiet
anders
das passiert so komische dinge jetzt
guckt sie sich hier ein
und sieht dass bei der zellteilung
notieren ihre eigenen zellen schon von
unserer protagonist drin ja das ist
jemand auch nur zweite reihe 2
ja also einmal kann man leider so eine
mutation nicht unterm mikroskop sehen
also eine mutierte zelle würde jetzt
nicht anders aussehen weil das sind ja
in der dna selber im änderungen die da
stattfinden und die das ist nicht so
dass die zellen auch immer blau leuchtet
und daran kann man das dann sehen dass
die mutiert ist erstmals im labor
zelllinien macht also wir selber machen
das auch dass wir in unserem labor
zellen genetisch verändern und auch auf
eine art und weise wie sie nicht in der
natur stattfindet dass wir wollen
manchmal bestimmte proteine die die
zelle herstellt markieren sodass die zum
beispiel leuchten also wenn diese zelle
beispielsweise das protein aktin macht
dann soll dieses aktive so markiert sein
dass es leuchtet und dazu fügen wir in
das genom von den zellen dna von einer
qualle ein wird man auch sagen kleine
natur will das nicht irgendwie
funktionierende maus und eine quelle ist
nicht so dass ist nur so ein bestimmter
ausschnitt aus dem genom von der quelle
das kann man an einer bestimmten stelle
in die dna von der maus inserieren und
wenn die jetzt dieses protein macht was
sie sowieso machen würde dann geben wir
einfach noch den zusatz befehl wie bei
seinen code mache dass das leuchtet
dieses blatt dass du da hast
was bekommst du wenn du sein erbgut
entschlüsselt was menschliche hox gene
saks was ist was bedeutet hawks
gene die den bauplan des körpers
definieren die physische struktur
und die pflanzen haben einen
menschlichen bauplan die arme hängen an
den schultern die beine an den hüften
das ist eigentlich unmöglich und dennoch
ist dass das was hier passiert
diese hox gene gibt wirklich die gehabt
irgendwie zur humor box also das ist
tatsächlich gibt zum bauplan gene die
quasi sagen da muss der kopf sein da
kommen die beiden hin dass das vordere
ende das dass hinter ende hier ist links
rechts und so weiter also erstmal so
legen den gruben bauplan was da passiert
ist soll ja sein dass pflanzen und
menschliche dna sich eigentlich
vermischt haben und das ist schon mal
noch unwahrscheinlicher als bei den brei
und weiblichen krokodile weil also
pflanzen zählen und tier zellen sind ja
wirklich fundamental unterschiedlich die
haben ganz andere bestandteile und
zellorganellen die kriegen ihre energie
auf ganz unterschiedliche weise die
pflanzen brauchen chlorophyll und damit
ihm photosynthese zu machen und
tierische zellen haben anderen
metabolismus und selbst wenn das wir
versuchen würde zusammen zu packen auch
nur irgendwie in die nähe bringen würde
die würden komplett gegeneinander
arbeiten und völlig unterschiedliche
enzyme produzieren also dass das es
wirklich irgendwas was so nicht
funktionieren
der schwimmer ist ein prisma aber er
bricht nicht nur lichtwellen nicht nur
funkwellen sondern auch die dns von
tieren der handliche dns
einfach jeder dns was meinst du mit
jeder dns sie meint damit unsere dns es
gibt ja heute werden so führten so seins
trash talk eigentliche begriff
aneinandergereiht werden die auch gar
keinen sinn ergibt dass star trek ist da
ganz groß drin so gehalten folgen so das
habe ich hier gerade auch gehört ist
rein vom licht funk welt und der
erstmals das erste beide das gleiche und
dania
impression das zdf
ist strange das finde ich zb bei dem
film auch richtig gut weil der also
natürlich gibt es da auch um die
darstellung von von wissenschaftlicher
forschung und diese
expeditionsteilnehmer die diese
spezielle area extra erforschen sollen
sind natürlich auch alles
wissenschaftler aber es ist auch so ein
bisschen noch so eine metaebene das ist
so natürlich wird hinter nicht ganz klar
was da genau passiert ist oder was da
noch passiert genau und so vieles wird
auch einfach offen gelassen aber ist ein
sehr schöner film der also wenn ihr also
in pink mit wissenschaft an und geht
dann immer mehr in so der science
fiction am ende wird es tatsächlich sehr
abstrakt aber auch eine sehr schöne art
und weise und ich finde es macht es
irgendwie nicht irgendwie so als
kopfhaut um zu sagen ja keine ahnung
jetzt die haben nicht nur konzept
angefangen das nicht zu ende gedacht
sondern ja das ist eine ganz andere
ebene gehoben ja die sehr kooperativ ist
seit 2001 aber mir gefallen wie man
vielen dank dass ihr da wart
dankeschön und schreibt uns bitte gerne
mal unten in die kommentare welche filme
welche serien mit dem videospiel
vielleicht auch wir hier dabei haben
sollten bei wissenschaftler reagieren
was ist super spannend was sollten uns
mal ansehen schreibt uns gerne ansonsten
macht ihnen fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig
habe keine klappe wir haben ja was ist
das funktioniert genauso gut da die
radprofis